Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the narration of
in the chapter of repentance of
the end of the story that we have been
reading for the past couple of mornings
with regards to the story of the man who
killed a hundred
people, took a hundred lives. One of
which we are sure was a Muslim life. One
of which we are sure was for all intents
and purposes a righteous man.
However, he wished to repent and he was
directed to go and leave his land and go
to a land of where there are people of
righteousness there and be part of their
community.
And on his way when he reached the exact
middle of the way, he passed away. And
so the angels of mercy and the angels of
punishment both came and began to
debate as to who is more rightful to
this man's soul.
So the angels of mercy
argued that they had more of a right to
him because he came
with respect to his state of being. Now
that he came
with his heart filled with
contrition and
came with the intention of turning over
a new leaf.
And the angels of punishment
argued with respect to his past that
he has never done anything of good in
his life. What does this mean?
We hear this often in narrations of the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam. He's never
done anything good. Well, obviously he
did the bare minimum of good. He was
Muslim or he wouldn't have been eligible
for paradise. Obviously he
saidahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
he sought out people of knowledge of the
revelations of Allah. He took their
advice and so forth. So what does this
mean?
Is it even possible to imagine
a person a human being who has never
done a single good thing in his life? Is
that possible? I mean evenl
even
is he not affectionate towards his
children or do some good somewhere
somehow in his life? The answer is yes.
There is no person who is entirely evil.
There is no person who is entirely good.
what is meant by this is nothing
worth mentioning. Nothing out of the
ordinary. He has not put forth for
himself anything worth mentioning. This
is what is intended by this statement.
[Silence]
And so an angel then came in the image
of a human being and they
agreed agreed to his judgment. They
made him a judge between the two
groups, the two factions here, the
angels of mercy and the angels of
punishment. Which what does this mean?
Why why is the prophet telling us that
an angel came in the in the form of a
man? Why didn't he come in the form of
an angel? This tells us the position the
human being holds in the angels. They
the the angels look up to the human
being. They find the human being as
worthy of it of their admiration because
of his potential and because of the
gifts that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
bestowed upon him. They have continued
to look up to the human being since the
first human being
when they fell in prostration to him.
So this is an honor for the human being.
forana.
[Silence]
for
multiple
The prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam then tells us that the judge
between them this angel in the form of a
human being
came and his judgment was measure the
distance between him and each of the two
lands and whichever of the two lands he
is closest to he is to that land he
will be considered of considered of its
people and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
then caused the
land of evil to
distance
and he caused the land of good to
come in closer to him and they found him
to be a handspan closer to the land of
righteousness and so he was considered
of its people and the angels of mercy
were the ones that took him. If a person
has a good intention,
if a person repents earnestly
and cleans his heart
and honestly reaches out to Allah and
places his cheeks on the threshold of
Allah's of the door to Allah's mercy.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will change
the shape of the earth in order to
accommodate him and have mercy upon him.
He will literally this is not a
figurative thing
when they explain these narrations. This
is a literal distance. He literally made
the evil
place
stretch further away and made the place
of goodness stretch in closer towards
him.
He literally changed the topography of
the earth. moved the whole earth around
with all of its mountains and all of its
grandeur in order to accommodate this
poor soul that had otherwise proven to
be nothing but a nuisance to society.
However, he reached out to Allah and
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is far more
generous than his servant.
And the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam
tells us that Allah himself said, "If my
servant reaches out to me a handspan, I
reach out to him a cubit.
And if he reaches out to me a cubit, I
reach out to him an arm's length. And if
he comes to me walking, I come to him
running. Subhanahu wa ta'ala.